this program is brought to you by Emory
University
now was that day on the tire place
getting my tires rotated and that's way
it happened actually meet me up
there earlier and it was going to take a
while so I told her to go home and just
sitting waiting for my arm you know for
my car to be completed and I start
feeling we're just the legs first felt
tired and then they got heavy and then
my hand got heavy and I'm psych hold her
i was on the panic and I called her and
when I called I was slurring so I didn't
know what was going on and you know she
could tell you from there what happened
up dying called her well after after I
talked to him I kind of had an idea that
might have been having a stroke he had
called his sister and left a message and
she called me immediately and said have
you talked to Al and I was like yeah
just talk to him I'm on my way to him
right now and she said he sounds really
bad and I said well I don't want to
think about what it is but I think he
may be what do you think it is and she
said I think he's having a stroke and I
said well what should i do should i
drive him to the hospital called on when
she said call 911 that was it a hung up
call 911 and got there where he was in
probably 30 seconds and was there and
probably about two minutes after I got
there he actually met me at the door and
when he came to the door he was dragging
his right side his right arm was limp
his he was limping on his leg and his a
little horror on his face
and they said that he probably had a
light stroke okay gave him the TPA
medication and within 20 minutes he was
doing better he wasn't slurring as much
he could move his arm more and then I
was saying he just just crashed I mean
his blood pressure went in the hospital
in the hospital in the emergency room
his blood pressure went low I thought
maybe he was bleeding on the brain they
took informed me a cat scan and with all
the shuffling around by the time we got
back from all that dr. villasana said
we've talked to Grady they're doing this
procedure down there that we can't do
here where they can put the medication
right into the clot and we're going to
lifelight you down there so I was like
okay
well as they explained to me that went
into his groin and when I went to his
brain to put the Austin yeah put a stent
in at this at that moment I didn't know
what all it was and dr. the head of the
bistro for dr. Frankel yes dr. Franco
call all the way in the end was down
there and said I need to get your
permission he told me exactly what it
was we're going to go up into his brain
through it leg and there's a ninety-six
percent chance that this will work and
there's a four percent chance that it
won't work and then he may even be worse
so I decided to go with the odds and
said okay those are good odds yeah yeah
he is a real miracle child because even
dr. Frankel the first night he said I
don't know if he's gonna make it through
you know that was when he was like oh my
gosh so the next day he came by the room
and every day after that that we were in
ICU which was about four days he came by
every single day instead I can't believe
you still here I mean he many bring
people by to look like a circus and
there's a brilliant person you know we
didn't think he would make it and now
look at and then now four months later
he's he's like what eighty-seven
eighty-eight percent
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University